so let me introduce our last speaker is
Oh before I introduce our last speaker
actually have couple announcement so
number one there's a happy hour after
the talk will be in the patio number two
tomorrow registration you have to go
through the door again to go through
security and enter so that's the only
entrance tomorrow morning not registers
just enter because we have to pass
through security alright so now let me
introduce Chris laughs rap he's a
software engineer at Google he will
giving the talk will assess Python
algorithm visualization in the browser
but i guess this light say something
else i guess there might be some
interesting story so chris has worked on
various programming framework stools and
projects and you can tell by all the
cool stickers are there and it's kind of
nice that most of them our Python now so
yes good so he has worked on various
tools ended up writing numerous
profiling and visualization tools for
protocol small talk JavaScript C++ Java
egl and Python and right now the latest
series is pi alba vez so for the bad for
to do Chris Thank You Diana so yes the
this is the last talk before we have
beers so I'm in between you and beers so
I thought like how can I make this talk
interesting this is like the last talk
of the day you all must be really tired
and faced out so this is actually going
to be three talks in one so I'm going to
do three talks in parallel so one theme
is Python algorithm visualization the
other one is how I got my job and then
the third one is jokes because we need
some jokes to actually get warmed up
during this talk all right so I
presented soma yeah my name is Chris
afrah I joined Google six weeks ago
before that I worked the bank of america
where we built a huge
stack of trading applications frameworks
all in Python at a time when I left we
had about 15 million lines of Python
written of trading applications on top
of that architecture and I did a lot of
training inside the bank in Python but I
couldn't talk about all of that topic
when I started interviewing with other
companies so Python algorithm
visualization is really my my business
card basically to get into those
interviews and talk to people about
things that I built I found out that it
doesn't really scale well on the display
that i have here because i didn't expect
the projects us to be so awesome as they
are here so i changed my whole
presentation environment to run best on
these things so let's see how far that
goes my entire talk will be demos so
there will be very few slides and i like
to show you a lot of like python code
and see how that visualizes so this is
one of the three talks the how you how
you get hired so if you want to get a
good job at a large organization or a
technical company doesn't have to be
Google can be facebook like here or like
the host of this event you basically
need these three pillars of excellence I
call them so you need to know the
technology need to know the theory
basically you need to know what a
sorting algorithm is and why it exists
and what the trade-offs are a spacetime
then that knowledge is useless unless
you have actually used it in practice if
you've built rail systems so on the left
it's like watching NBA games and knowing
all the stars in the NBA the one in the
middle is you actually having played in
high school in college and having like
it played at least 10,000 hours of
basketball those are two different
things often we get people in that try
to get a job in my previous organization
and and they have a computer science
degree and they come in to become a
programmer and they don't know how to
program it's just unbelievable
so that that is something you want to
filter out in these interviews that's
why I have to do these tests on the
whiteboard just to see if you can
program it's like yeah okay so those two
things if you know them if you know your
theory and yeah and you have done a lot
of coding and hacking or whatever it
still doesn't mean that you will be
successful in a large organization to be
really successful there you have to
enable other people you have to
manipulate other people if you want to
call it that so you have to be
self-aware you have to know what your
limitations are what your strengths are
and this is why we asked questions and
interviews like so so tell me about your
strengths and weaknesses so the only
reason we are with like that those those
questions are asked is to see are you
self aware and do you know how to fix
your own limitations and how do you
enable other people and grow other
people I found that the best way of
learning by the way is actually to sign
up for talks like this you don't have to
go to a larger audience but you can
start at the meetup for instance so if
you have a hobby just talk about your
hobby at a meetup the next step up would
be writing a book on a topic so if you
want to learn something about a
particular topic sign up to publish a
book on this that will really focus your
attention to learning the material a
block is that somewhere in the middle
and these days you can there's this many
ways of like demonstrating your
knowledge of a topic and use that as a
sort of a motivator to get going so this
brings the two together the two talks
without the jokes so I started learning
algorithms because the last time i did a
sorting algorithm was 20 years ago and i
thought like if I'm at the whiteboard
and I have to explain the difference
with the merge sort and quicksort I have
no idea so I started studying but i
can't read technical books anymore i
don't know you guys but if i buy a book
you know you did about halfway okay i
want to do some actual coding so i
started practicing the algorithms but
then I saw the deaths of waste I'm
writing these algorithms I'm throwing
them away and I still don't know how
merge short relates
quicksort so as I started drawing
pictures basically and I wanted to
automate dad want to store them
somewhere so then I got ahold of Google
App Engine and that's where i post both
my algorithms and the visualization
scripts which I will demonstrate now and
show you all the ins and outs of it so
this poster I presented the couple of
weeks ago at PyCon in Montreal and I was
invited to give a talk on the topic here
so that's why we're standing here now so
these blue buttons are demos so I will
do demos life and the site itself so the
presentation here is special especially
done for for this talk here but normally
it will look like this so you go to PI
algo vez that's about 50 algorithms here
and if you click on one of them so for
instance pyar ki meets then it will
bring up the editor on the Left make the
font a bit big bigger to the editor on
the Left visualization script on the
bottom and you can play back the
execution here so you can look back in
time and there's also sound involves so
you play some peeps in there ok so I do
the same thing here but now I just
rearranged the tiles a little bit
differently so you get a little bit
bigger font and a bigger picture on the
right so the left is the algorithm so
these are the steps that you have to go
through to get a good job and how we
visualize that is by drawing letters in
different colors so let's start with a
real algorithm so bubble sort we all
know bubble sort I really still don't
really know how it works but this is the
algorithm so there's a for loop and
that's not a for loop and you compare
two numbers and if they're one is bigger
than the other you do something you swap
them around so exactly how it goes like
Gaza go from right to left birthright
and
how does this work that's hard to
predict so let's start visualizing this
so we don't have a visualization yet I
want to show you what's going on inside
so the simplest thing is to say I'm
going to show the state of the algorithm
which is captured really in the in the
variable called data so you can see I
have a list here that I populate with
random numbers between 0 and 10 and I
take 10 of them so i'm basically sorting
the numbers 0 to 10 29 sorry range is up
to nine so data at some point if you
like imagine you set a breakpoint in
this code and you enter at line line for
and you're somewhere halfway in the
sorting algorithm and if you look at
data like that array you can visualize
the values and then you have a feeling
of where we are then you go to the next
line you do this again and again again
again and if you put all these pictures
together you gather you get a movie
basically so let's do that so here for
script i'm going to say so the simplest
way of visualizing this algorithm is to
say it just represent it as a text so
you could see it walked by you can go
back in time so i can drag the slider
here and if i show the algorithm you can
see where we were in the algorithm that
point in time so it it starts off all
the way the left and then runs for a
while run to a while and then it's done
so the text is a little bit small but it
does show you the state so let's make it
a little bit bigger so let's try 25
pixels it's a bit better we can try a
different font as well and maybe a
different color so you get you get
control basically the position the color
and the text in this declarative session
here so how this works is that imagine
setting a breakpoint at each line and
each line that runs we run this script
and then we record them all
and then replay them so we have 130
steps and we start off all the way to
the left where it's mangled up and if
you progress in time you get to the end
is eventually it sorted numbers so
that's step one step two is show each of
the value as a rectangle to make a bar
graph so now we're going to make our own
bar chart out of nothing so first of all
we want the rectangle and let me move
this one a little bit higher so it
doesnt sit in the way so I'm going to
make a rectangle at position 100 100
let's do 400 ha wide and 250 hi let's
see what I get so I get that rectangle
there that looks good this one may be at
50 so there's an event listener that
looks at my script and as soon as it
changes it redraws the entire
visualization this runs on a server it
doesn't run here so every time I make a
change that get sent to a server runs
there comes back and then shows here so
this is the beginning of my bar bar
graph so now I need to render each
different value in that array so let's
do a for loop for I want to know which
one it is and what the value is so I'm
going to use an enumeration and
enumerate and I'm going to run over the
data elements and then for each one I'm
going to draw another rectangle so where
I'm going to draw the rectangles they're
going to be in this in this box here
from left to right so the X will be a
value of well we started a hundred and
then n is the number of the bar they
were drawing so here I can see n times
so I have 400 so I got 10 so 40 in total
and then the Y is let's start at the top
so that's like a hundred and then how
high will it be that will be
the height will be basically the value
over this area so it's between 0 and 10
and I totally have 150 so that's do 15
times and value here so let's see what
that gives me so that's my bar chart it
actually works it goes up and down the
one with zero is hardly visible so let's
make that let's introduce a variable
that makes it easier to handle it is so
the height is 15 times V and so let's
replace that variable they are so you
can you can do any Python in this in
this script it just runs in the same
context as the original code I can refer
to all the variables in the original
code as well and 0 doesn't show up so
let's just add three so then at least we
got that little little bar there's that
we know that it has a value you can see
that one here not so that works it's a
bit controversial and I like normally we
draw bar charts upwards right so let's
change the location there so we need a
y-coordinate and that would be let's see
we're 100 350 minus B so that's the sort
of the height and then rather than the
fixed 100 will make it at that location
so we're getting close you can see I can
use up more space so rather than 15
let's try 22 that's a bit better so you
can now immediately see that the
algorithm works well I mean it's sorts
so yes we got a working actually this
was a big thing for me because I was
trying to re-implement all these sorting
algorithms and often you make a mistake
like an edge condition and especially
merge short and binary search has that
as that problem so drawing a
visualization is a really good
reinsurance that the the code is there i
almost typed in DD because i have VI
bending
findings in the other one so gotta
unlearn that right now for the demo but
ok so we have this working and so the
next step says show the current values
of Y and J so if you see here the two
loops one has a variable called I and
the other one is j so if I see those
values and I can actually go see them
like go left and right so that would be
good thing to visualize so what I really
want to do is rather than draw just a
rectangle I want us to show the collar
with a different one so let's already
introduced that so if you wonder like
what what things can you actually draw
so we have a text and a rectangle so
these are the primitives that you can
use so we have text line racked circle
arc and bar chart and these were the
only the primitives that I came up with
just rather arbitrary but these are the
ones that I needed to do the 50
algorithms and I think you don't need a
whole lot more than that so it's all
right let's go back to our code so we
need a caller variable now so the color
let's make it red if N equals I and
elves make it green if N equals J and
else make it light gray so now we can
see all the I and J actually media
chowder in the middle somewhere and
everything works yes sorry of course it
works so I really constructed a bar
chart here but we have a built-in bar
chart so let's forget about all the crap
there you can just say bar chart 100 100
400 wide 250 high over data is the
syntax correct a bar chart
so why did I make a typo hmm i think i'm
feeling my oh there it is it's a little
small you can see that the numbers are a
little tiny there so there's another
parameter in bar chart that's a scale so
the scale you can change that so i can
say scale is 30 see if that's better
it's almost there 25 that's nice this
will also let me scale up a bit better
if I have more than 10 let's do 30
numbers now then my range so normally i
would make a function here that
calculates the maximum and then but now
i just hard code it and let's say seven
so another one is you can highlight one
of the bars that's built into the bar
chart so the highlight is a variable so
here i can say highlight equals I and
then you can see where red is going so
you can combine the technique I had
before with this technique and show you
some extra which will show you in the
next couple slides okay and the last one
is more a logical test so so if the
algorithm actually works so we're going
to print a text and it's going to say
okay if sort of data actually is data
else fail we need to put it somewhere so
let's put it let's see you've 50 and 450
does that work
alright the phone this a bit small but
you can see like it was failing all the
time let's go back in time so at some
point and we get almost to the end of
the algorithm it's already sorted by now
but we're not done yet because we
haven't verified so if you can you can
proceed you can also change the speed
here so i could say like slow and then
just say play and then it keeps me
playing from there on and if you want to
make it really small slow you can say
snail and then there's also molasses but
we won't run the whole thing in molasses
that takes a really long time you can
also do a beep here so i can say let's
generate a sound at a certain frequency
so something here here ball is probably
in two thousand range and times so I
times 100 and let's do this for 500
milliseconds I was still in molasses
medium
all right you can change that frequency
like if you make it like just so it's
all a little bit lower now if you make a
J then you get a different pattern you
can do this for hours so those were the
primitives the third part of the of the
year talk is jokes and it's really hard
to make jokes because you offend people
all the time so you cannot make any
discriminatory jobs not about other
people but I think you can make jokes
about other programming languages that
that's okay I would think so so I'm
going to make a lot of jokes about other
programming languages so this one a smug
Java actually like Java but it's like we
all like to hate other languages as
Python programmers so this algorithm is
2,300 years old so it's not something
new that we do algorithms this is
actually invented by a Greek ian guy and
yeah yeah 300 years before Christ was
born and the interesting part about the
algorithm is that it was hard to solve a
topological problem like people had a
hint that there was a relation between
the the the radius of a circle and the
circumference and they all thought like
it was around three and actually for a
long time people was a rule it was three
and so archimede wanted to figure out
like what it was and he the interesting
part about his approach is that he
turned the topological problem into an
algorithmic problem so he turned it into
a mathematical problem basically and all
he did was was calculating numbers and
he got really close actually so I do
like six here and the number of sides
128 he got as close as 96 and by hand
this is a lot of work like 2,300 years
ago
so he got really close actually to
estimating the value of pi so the
algorithm here it basically just like if
you go back here so you see the value of
visualization here so I can explain and
by show you pictures that's so much
easier than showing the code the code is
there on the left but who cares so we
started with four sides ya hear so now
you're calculating pi so you have four
edges so of course we're way off like
it's 1.5 we're not even close so we
start like going to the right and and
the closer we get like and then we have
four and then 16 so you basically just
calculate the length of this one this
one this one this one this one this one
and then you add them all up and then
you come to value for pie and eventually
if you get like really to the side like
six so let's do a little bit higher than
that like eight I have to rerun it we're
interesting a moiré patterns as well in
this you start you see these you get
these really weird like this one here
this one line is like bizarre anyway so
that's a one way of calculating pi the
other one did this one I really don't
understand so this algorithm here this
calculates pie and this is a famous one
is by the trig natsuki brothers they're
from Ukraine and they did this in 1984 I
believe and they calculated PI to 2
million digits and they did this by
writing jib they built around mainframe
basically in the rendus on the in their
apartment in New York and they run this
algorithm no idea how it works you can
see this factorial decimals all I could
do is is print out the values I couldn't
like imagine even like how to visualize
this so this is my poor visualization
here
but it gets really close so you can see
three point 14 15 and if you run out on
a real computer you can go like it yeah
infinite numbers and they get pretty
good so the jokes with text I want I
won't read out but you can read them so
this is the third way of calculating pi
and I think this is the unique 'used
unique is the most unique one so imagine
you have a table you draw lines on the
table and then you have needles that you
throw on the table randomly and then you
see if they touch the line or not so
here you can see some of them are red
and that means that they're touching the
line so the one on the top right here
they're actually touching this line here
and it's a little bit hard to see but
they're gray lines in there so if you
assume in a bit yeah okay if I don't
zoom in so now you can probably see the
line here that's like a gray line there
and if you then count the total divided
by the red ones you get pie so almost
you can almost pie and this is because
pythons randomizer is not really
distributed well if you do this with a
real like it's just the real table and
you throw things and then apparently if
you go over a thousand needles or so you
get like really really good
approximation of pie so this has to do
with distribution with probability
theory because the chance that you touch
one of these lines has to do with the
angle and then the distance between the
lines and of course the this this the
space in between these two is carefully
chosen to be twice as long as the as the
needle length so so you would think that
this visualization is rather complex but
still is very simple so this is the
script to draw the thing on the right
this was one of the more elaborate ones
so this one took me
probably an afternoon to get the sorting
once you do in five minutes if she
showed up when i set up biographies my
plan was to make it open so other people
could contribute their algorithms as
well so i'll give you a few examples
here of people having done that so this
is by NAMM win and he does a basically a
substring determination algorithm so
that's called horse pool the boy or more
horse Polly algorithm and his
visualization script is here so this is
a little bit well it's still simple the
algorithm is a little bit longer I try
to get all my algorithms within 25 lines
because I think like if I can explain
how something works in 25 lines you can
actually get it so I will do some goat
yeah Python golf to make this code a
little bit shorter but that's I'm not
going to complain about somebody
contributing to my site though so joke
time so for four friends chemical
engineer electrical engineer mechanical
engineer and a computer scientist they
go on a road trip so they're on the way
halfway the car just stops and the
mechanical engineer says oh there's
something wrong with the engine probably
a Pistons like they're they're getting
too hot and they don't go up in the air
and then the chemical engineer starts
laughing is yeah I know of course now
that must be what's with your gasoline
like the is big honking up we haven't
used the car in a long time so let's
just clear out the the gasoline and then
the electrical engineer says he have no
idea it must be the spark plugs is like
yeah and all the time like the computer
scientists sitting in the back and
saying nothing and so the three of them
they fight for a while and then and then
they look at a computer scientist it
says like aren't you speaking up what do
you think is wrong with the car and he's
just like well I have no idea but I
think that if we all go outside of the
car close the doors and then come back
in it will probably work
okay this is another example that
somebody contributed so this one is by
King Robert King and I can see why you
use that user ID because Robert King is
a very common name but you can find him
here so that's a and I think this
algorithm is just unbelievable so if you
if you draw this shape on each of these
you pick a random point and you draw
this shape on each of the lines that you
find in the in the polygon here you can
calculate the circumference by just
adding them all up and it's like what
did the surface area so there's the
algorithm again it's a little bit longer
to explain here but the script itself is
not that complex so if you're interested
in that just look it up another joke
putting them in more jokes because we're
getting at towards the beer now so this
one is a is a google search page so you
type in recursion and do you see the
joke you guys see it well maybe we meant
the recursion and it goes to the same
page
this is another contribution by I think
this is called other Eric not to be
confused with the other Eric Eric I know
so other eric this person he let let's
see what did he do what is this Shannon
entropy ok so the script here is really
interesting it just prints out elephant
so I'll get in touch with Derek to to
see what's wrong with the visualization
but it doesn't work right now so I
probably I probably broke it for him
sorry ok that's visualization and we had
some jokes so get back to hiring so if
you're a computer scientist like i am
i'm particularly weak at seeing politics
of my organization and i don't like to
sell myself i don't like to i just like
to build stuff and get credit for it so
I so these books really teach you how to
influence other people they're extremely
helpful if you want to interview
especially the one on the left I
actually read this book for my
interviews and there are really
interesting tips about like yeah I can
make other people like you so and on
these two books if you have only time to
read two books read these two because
they actually are the total knowledge of
the entire universe in two books
and the one on the right is actually
extremely helpful so it's a really thin
book it's like 35 pages or whatever and
it's written in the 70s or so but it's
still highly vulnerable and who's seen
the movie Groundhog Day okay who can
tell me what it's about so you think
about oh it's about a guy that wakes up
every day and there's and and he repeats
the same day over and over nowhere but
that's not what the movie is about the
movie is about him being a dork and not
recognizing what she likes and then
every day is got a chance to discover a
little bit more about that and and at
the end he so practiced said that that
she actually started liking him and then
they fall in love and then it's over so
this is a really smart way of selling
these books here so go see a groundhog
day again and you will see it in
different eyes I've shown you some
sorting algorithms numerical algorithms
are also favorite interview questions so
draw me a Fibonacci function that
produces Fibonacci from here go okay
I'll draw a Fibonacci so you start
writing Fibonacci that returns like a
and b is 0 and 1 and while it's good and
then you return the whole list okay so
this one is contributed by somebody else
I won't complain too much about it but
this is not a really pythonic way of
doing this if you were in James Powell
talk this morning about generators the
problem with this particular incarnation
of the algorithm is that you create all
the elements into a list ahead of time
so if you're asking for the first
million then I have to create an array
and run all 1 million before I can give
you the first one the visualization
doesn't show that but so that's a
but it does work it's it's generating
the numbers here the visualization
script itself is also rather
straightforward so you draw a grid based
on the value you paint the meter orange
or green and that's it so you're
interested in doing Fibonacci function
in a more lazy way there's a generator
function and that looks like this so you
have yield statements that yield the
first 10 and then yield one and then it
starts yielding the next number and you
have basically remember the stack frame
with the state of that function at that
point and then it returns so this will
never calculate more numbers than it
actually needs until your start asking
for the next one the visualization here
this is the most elaborate one that I
developed this one shows you not only
the Fibonacci numbers here so we start
off it also has nice if you can see so
you start with the numbers here you go
up and if you divide the top one by the
previous one you get this number and the
closer you get like at some point it
starts to level off so we don't really
need to go any further than this if this
is the precision that we're after and
this is a very special number so this is
called the golden ratio and that this is
like the broccoli number you see that if
we were in seashells and whatever so
this is the meaning of life here the
meaning of life and seven lines of
Python the scripts gets a little bit
more complex here so I break my own rule
39 lines but I have rotation in here and
spinning and sound so ok so that's
numbers talking about numbers
another one is is topology and
Mandelbrot so Mandelbrot is famous for
for having really nice fractals and this
is an algorithm for generating fractals
so I don't even know how it works it has
this for loops and it as an imaginary
part so I didn't write this algorithm I
found this on this page here but I did
write D visualization so how does that
work it's pretty stay forward actually
if you have the numbers you just have
two for loops and you draw rectangles
with different colors and the colors are
basically a function of their value so I
I emphasize here blue as you can see
blue gets a better ratio of the number
so if you change that ratio so like 1812
for so let's make that 12 I'm just
winging this I didn't even never even
tried this before so I would imagine
that the picture would be more red now
it's actually more great okay but you
can play with the numbers there of green
huh okay it's more green now yeah it was
green yes yes of course green did I say
red and often in interview digital's a
popular question is how do you generate
the first 100 prime numbers and the NIMH
one would be oh say so to know if 47 is
a prime number you have to see if you
can divide it by 3 x 4 x 5 x 6 with it
and then you you have this for loop that
tries to see if one of these numbers is
a divisor of the number of your after
and if you write that up then the
interviewer will ask you like well is
there a way to do this a little bit
faster and yeah I don't have to go all
the way of course i can stop halfway and
then later on your discover you don't
really have to stop happy you can even
stop earlier and and then if you realize
that if you
no all the prime numbers before then you
can use those prime numbers to see if
your number is a prime number and then
you can make it a generator function so
it only produces the next so this is
like an elaboration of different steps
of your reduction of the complexity of
the algorithm and and do a careful
space-time trade-off so the practice of
remembering previous values to come up
with the next one that is usually called
dynamic programming and use that as well
in more elaborate algorithms that will
hopefully have time for so patterns are
ubiquitous and that's the whole idea
about visualization is that you see
unexpected patterns so who has to do
fizzbuzz in an interview anybody yes 0 1
2 3 4 yes so I think this bus was
invented by Facebook fizzbuzz facebook
why else would you do FF and be as you
can see like it all leads up to FB
facebook right now and by visualizing
this you can see the patterns so you can
see the blue one is the F the B FB FB
and I window all together like three and
five together then we see FB so the
visualization here is basically just a
loop and I draw these numbers and I said
different colors if there and I say 15
so I do 15 per column I can also try 9
gives you a different pattern so now
it's nine high so the pattern is a
little a little bit more yeah messed up
so then the pattern is like ffff
Facebook FF facebook so this bus I mean
sir okay another joke days long java
programmer and the Python programmer
they both have to go to the bank to get
some money so they walk into the bank
and there's a long line so they're
waiting in line
and all of a sudden they hear a lot of
noise at the entrance of the bank so
they look around and there's this guy
running in with a gun in his hand and
like in masks owners and and he's like
he's going to say like hold up hold your
hands and when he does that he raises
his his his mask so he can see his face
so everybody's like staring at him or
like what kind of robbery is that so he
walks up to the first person and he says
like did you see my face and the person
yeah it was kind of obvious right so she
shoots him down so wats up to the next
person did you see my face in the guises
yeah it was like Sheree speech him that
so wats up to the Python program and he
says like did you see my face he says
like no but the Java program I did okay
sorting back to sorting we're going to
do some grass later on each Y and this
is an algorithm called comb sort and as
you can see from the visualization it's
it's sort of a linear search so you go
back and forth back and forth until
everything is sorted so there's two
kinds of ways of sorting algorithms one
is that that up and down and going over
things and you insert values in other
places and the other one is to divide
and conquer where you split up the
problem in different parts so you will
see the difference in in the algorithm
show up in the visualizations as well so
that's comb sort this is cocktail sword
and I was thinking cocktail sorts that's
probably where have drinks so let's
visualize the nice glasses data drinking
and it almost looks like a party right
there like coming together and so the
visualization for that is not too hard
you can see I use a bar chart as we did
earlier in the in the first exercise and
I draw some extra stuff at the bottom
here I show some numbers so you can see
the values and these glasses are drawn
like little lines here so a blue line
and a red line makes up a glass so you
can see this script runs at every single
line here
whatever it runs so we go back in time
here so for each frame we're drawing
this entire picture here so the entire
bar chart is drawn in SVG and JavaScript
with rectangles and with text and lines
or whatever so I think that's really
amazing that like the speed with which
you can do things in JavaScript these
days gnome sword is invented by a
professor of mine at the free university
of amsterdam and that's why i call a
cobalt or sword which is the Dutch name
for Nonie so again it's the same
elaboration on bubble sort you go from
left to right and you figure out which
ones to replace and in sword where so
this is all an insertion sort
elaboration so this is a very generic
joke you can use this in your daily work
just substitute the word regular
expression with something else my
favorite one is XML CSV like so come up
with with an acronym and you can reuse
it a lot of people a lot of person ask
me like so wow this this visualization
stuff you build is really amazing as
like long did it take you to build this
and then I say 25 years and they laugh
but this is true so this i did in 1994
and this is a visual debugger at the
time that we didn't even have colors on
monitors so this is all black and white
it's not because it came out of a paper
but this is really the colors that we
have gray scale and it shows you like
yeah in the time novel things like I I
instrumented every single function that
running inside of this c++ program and
then draw a pixel here for each line
each function that you draw so I
basically give you a hash code for each
function and you start to see patterns
there so if something happens I also
show you which objects call which other
objects
and since that time I've actually been
looking for but Peter Norfolk halt I had
a call with Peter last week he works at
Google as well and he called it what
you're looking for is an understanding
language basically so I've been
searching for an understanding language
for the last 25 years and the one I
found this is called Python you can see
this was my experiment in 94 so I have
the code on top left and then i have my
understanding language on the bottom
left and then my visualization on the
right so this starts to look like the
stuff that we've seen already right so I
have some state on top you can call it
model and then at the bottom i have
declarative visualization you can call
it a view and whenever the model changes
the view updates and that's a very
powerful way of of symbolically
visualizing code by having the
declarative binding between your your
state and your visualization so this one
shows you an elevator simulation which
is like really impossible to view from
looking at the code and from setting
breakpoints you couldn't really see the
problem what was wrong with the
algorithm this one is a little bit in
the middle so not 20 years ago 10 years
ago and I worked on the Eclipse project
I wanted to understand how plugins
interacted with each other and I just
had a young son who was into gaming
starting to like Buzz Lightyear and I
thought like okay I'm going to use
lasers and I'm going to have planets for
each of the plugins each plug-in is a is
a is a planet here and when they
communicate this end lasers to each
other and this is really an execution
pattern so while eclipse was running you
could see who was interacting with what
and then you can double-click on you I
and then see and set breakpoints in the
code and then it became a normal
debugger so you can see this has been a
hobby for a long time
so the generic one is called insertion
sort so you can see how it works so
let's stop time like somewhere here the
one on 22 is the red 123 is a really
small one so that's out of order that
has to go somewhere on the left but we
don't know yet where so the algorithm
will have to search and it's actually
walking left words to find the right
spot for that one okay that was the
previous one but now we get to the
little red one so we'll have to move
this all the way to the left so you can
see it's finding trying to find the
correct spot for it and if you see what
it's doing it's actually doing linear
search and we all know how bad linear
search is so what's best what's better
than linear search that's binary search
yes so all sorting algorithms have been
invented in the 50s in the 60s literally
that's where all of them came out of
that time frame so doing the
visualization stuff that I've done for
this biographies I think I came up with
a unique new one so this is binary
search insert sort and I call a bus
sword so we go back to the same states
let's see if we can rewind it here yeah
it's about there so we see the problem
here we have a small one here and we
have to find the right spot so it should
go all the way to the left I think that
was the finest bottle ready and it's
there
so I gotta find a spot for this number
here and so rather than do a linear
search as you saw in the beginning we're
actually doing binary search here and
binary search is between zero and the
previous one because by the time we get
to like number 19 we know that
everything between zero and 18 is
already sorted so we don't have to do
linear search we can actually find the
right spot a lot faster all right so
that's a search and sort divide and
conquer works differently is you split
up the search problem into different
areas so if you saw it come by I'll run
it again so this is recursively doing
portions of the sorting algorithm so you
split it up into split up into split up
into you sort that and then you merge
with the other ones so you can see
essentially here it's merge sort is two
recursive calls and then merge the two
results the other one is quicksort and
an interesting once it's sort of in the
middle which is heapsort and if you use
a heap queue which is a data structure
to store things in a tree in a certain
order where you can say like give me the
minimum value back and give me the
maximum value back and that hip Q can be
used in that way as a what's called the
priority queue so if you have to
schedule jobs you can put them all in
there and then you can save give me the
first one and then you will do fair
distribution with the one with the
highest priority so the priority here is
defined by the value so you can use a
heap queue here which is really an
interesting array it's a special array
where the numbers are organized in such
a way
that on the first level you have one
number on the next level you have two
numbers and then the next level you have
four numbers so if you look at it from
left to right this would be your first
level and this would be your second
level and then you get the third level
and then the fourth level and so on so
the hip Q is nothing more than a list
it's a very efficient that data for data
wise it's very efficient data structure
and it uses it with indexing to use it
as a sort of hierarchical data structure
you can also answer the question like
what's your minimum value and then you
take that out so if you build a hip q
like this and then you take the first
number out see where you get to the end
yeah now we're done so now I'm going to
pop out the numbers here you can see he
pop eep so the kiss me the one with the
highest priority which is the one with
the lowest number so we started with one
so one disappeared now two is the top
one and then the tree gets rebalanced
the tree the heap Q gets reordered so
that it's imbalance again and that goes
on so so you can then extract all the
numbers and then if you added them up in
a list like we do here they get a sordid
result so this is a very complex way of
doing sorting basically
okay nobody's laughing anymore any
better jokes quicksort is another divide
and conquer algorithm this one is much
more difficult to visualize then merge
short for instance which just splits it
up and emerges it you can see the
patterns there what we do here is we we
take a random number out of the lists of
things that we have to sort and then we
take all the ones that are less than
that number and all the ones that are
right bigger than that number and then
we basically do recursion so you can see
quicksort on the left parts and
quicksort on the right part and yeah you
really need to visualize this as a tree
and I didn't come up with the right one
yet so I guess okay it looks cool and it
gives you a nice sound but it doesn't
really tell you how the algorithm works
that's so I wasn't I'm not really too
happy with this this one here it's an
improvement of a quick sort and this was
done in 1968 or something or 78 we're
all like roll too late in the game like
if we would have worked on this in the
70s than we could have made it up but
now it's Sedgwick who came up with this
he said like well rather than take a
random number let's take one like like a
range and then let's see and maybe maybe
we can get a better result so we got a
far better is all born
we can see it's still recursive so it
will cause recursive numbers there so to
understand recursion you have to
understand recursion so there's also a
typical question and interviews so they
make you write something recursive like
Fibonacci and then they tell you like
can you make this a non recursive
version so then you have to understand
how stacks work basically so we have a
stack here I call it work and I pushed
work on to the stack and when I don't
want to get the next one off I say pop
and I met Raymond headed juror at PyCon
and he came up to me and he ran up to me
and he says like I wrote that and he
pointed at my t-shirt I said no no I
wrote that no no no I wrote that and he
pointed enumerate so he wrote the
enumerate function and when he saw this
example he said like oh please can you
not use pop zero please use a deck and
so so I still have to rewrite this one
to satisfy him but you can see this is
the quicksort algorithm without
recursion there's no recursive calls to
quicksort so why would you do this like
why would you make it so much more
complex your code here this is more
complex than the previous one which is
much more readable but the problem with
the recursive one is that you may run
out of stec space there's this a certain
limit of how deep languages will allow
you to make recursive calls and
sometimes your data structure is just
too big to do it in recursion and then
you have to think about like how can I
avoid the recursion by doing my own
stack management basically so by now you
must be wondering how all this works I
hope so the way works is you have this
editor etc and top which is implemented
in code mirror that's a JavaScript
library to allow you to edit code in the
browser and its really advanced it even
has vin bindings so you can do VI key
bindings
and the bottom one is also a code mirror
when the code since the browser comes
back eventually i render it in html5
using canvas and d 3gs so how does it
work on the on the server side on the
server side we received the request for
the algorithm and the visualization
script and I run that in a sandbox so
there's a special piece of python that i
wrote to make sure that you don't import
cysts and then you can't go to the file
system you can't open urls things like
that and then I record every single line
so in Python this really cool feature if
you haven't seen this yet look it up
it's called sis that set race where you
can very quickly define your own
function that is called for every single
line in your code they can set a filter
and you can say I only want to like look
at the stuff that runs in the script
that I'm actually interested in not in
the libraries down in the code and I see
you have one minute left oh dear and
then you render it eventually send it
back to the browser so the pseudo code
looks like this i define a sandbox I use
quite interesting Python constructs that
are like context managers monkey
patching I measure how long it takes so
if you take more than 10 seconds I
actually stopped you and this will runs
in the browser so I showed this to a
call a colleague of mine at Google he
started the same day as I did and he
said like oh this is cool stuff let me
try and break in okay so we took in five
minutes and oh dear let me fix that one
and then it took him 10 minutes okay
yeah I didn't think of that okay a half
an hour and so the last time I blocked
it up he didn't get in so anybody here
who gets in yeah I don't know have to
find a price but i'll i'll buy you a
beer tonight or something but any send
me this meme so i think that's a we all
like memes in in google so that's a
graphs are cool so i'll just quickly
show you the the end result so this is
Dykstra which basically an envelope of
things that you look for and you for
each one you extend the envelope with
the minimum one that you can find and
this is an approximation of finding the
shortest path there's different
algorithms that you can try convex hulls
is a nut it's a nice one this is also
contributed by somebody else I didn't
write this which finds the enclosure of
a graph basically the minimum spanning
tree is another one which is a classic
graph or algorithm so you can see the
algorithm is pretty short it's like 10
lines visualization gets a little bit
more complex but still okay I didn't
plan to be viral I just wrote this thing
and at some point somebody sent this to
facebook to all his friends and they
start they all started hammering my
server at the same time and then because
I signed up with a free program I'm
Dutch so you tried the free one first it
actually brought that my server so I got
an email that says like you ran out of
budget and so when there are three
clicks later I just enabled billing and
since then I paid one dollar so okay so
that's nice thing about a google app
engine is that you can very quickly
react to two changes and it's all
transparent i mean i just enable billing
you can choose what kind of server you
like and it all works automatically this
is another one there's this uh another
seamless through in the past
me if you recognize this one no no so
there's a somebody uploaded 70,000 or
80,000 videos of 11 seconds each and
this is the original one at YouTube
they'll stop this though and this is my
version so the script is really easy you
can see so you draw a rectangle you draw
a rectangle and you do beep so I so i'm
going to upload ninety ninety thousand
of them how's that sound conspiracy
theories a lot of people say oh there
must be aliens like using no no that's
not it is ok I got a lot of more about
trees some breadth-first search versus
depth first search it's really
interesting to see the algorithms there
so this is breath so you can see like
waves going up and down whereas if you
look at depth first search it's much
more chaotic because like up and down
like this and the same thing if you are
doing non-recursive and again you can
see we use a snack okay I'll start with
a final jogo this actually double joke
this is a so there's a chemical engineer
and I can oh no I already told that one
so you're interested in my work is
really inspired by breath Victor if you
have never seen his work go look it up
it's just unbelievable Python tutor is
also very inspirational for me but I can
see normal being studious stuff so I
wanted to build an environment that I
tried to give to you so that it's easier
for you guys to build something similar
so summarizing on the job hiring is last
light so the theory is right books do
presentations it's really fun go apply
your work do something with it get some
experience and then the other part is
hard but yeah just stay calm so thank
you very much I run out of time for
questions but we have beers
I'm the guy wearing the shirt so you can
come to the beer centimeter do we have
time for questions or not not when I
know I've got a signal nut all right
thank you all right everyone the happy
hour will be at the building 15 son of
ping and pong foyer enjoy yourself